there's a carb more deadly more
dangerous than actual sugar okay that
you need to know about and very
unfortunately you probably have been
consuming this carb for a very long time
without knowing it and it's a little
conflicting because it causes belly fat
diabetes and gut inflammation yet it's
considered safe how could that be that
doesn't make sense this carbohydrate is
not a sugar it's not sweet yet it
behaves like sugar not just behaves like
sugar but way worse than sugar on the
glycemic index so if we take a look at
this little Index right we have right
here table sugar 65 right and then we go
up to a 100 this is on the glycemic
index that's glucose right 100 is
glucose the same as white bread you know
other type of refined carbohydrates and
the reason why glucose is 100 and table
sugar is 65 is because table sugar has
glucose and fructose and fructose is
lower on the glycemic index so uh it
averages out to 65 but look at this
above glucose 110 to
136 that's where this ingredient is I
want to see if you can guess what this
is go ahead and comment down below okay
I'm going to give you some Clues it's in
chips it's in crackers it's in bread
pasta cereals infant formulas soups
pretty much all the dressings it's in
light beer it's in energy drinks it's in
a lot of support products especially if
you're running longdistance marathons uh
there's a certain carbohydrate that they
give you to keep going it's in a lot of
the protein powders to help you
supposedly build muscle mass and these
ingredients right here are very
interesting because if you have less
than five grams per serving size you can
make it zero carbohydrates I mean that
doesn't make sense like how can you have
something that is like 500 milligrams in
that area and have it be zero on the
label that is what's called a loophole
that industry uses to put these
carbohydr in to make it seem like
there's no sugar and no carbs and so
it's all about the serving size if it's
0.5 grams that's 500 milligrams like how
big is that well think of a capsule of
something that's roughly about 500
milligrams it's in artificial sweeteners
it's also in many sugarfree products
right for diabetics which is legally
correct because it's not classified as a
sugar even though it behaves like a
sugar but it's a carbohydrate so they
can actually claim it's sugar free what
a scam so here you are trying to lose
weight and getting off sugar and then
you're consuming this thing that's worse
than sugar this could be a barrier oh
the seasoning mixes they put this
ingredient in a lot of the seasoning
mixes and the purpose of this video once
I reveal what this is is to for force
you to start reading the ingredients
right so you can avoid this ingredient
because it's in so many different things
it's in a lot of your supplements and
you know what its main purpose is it's a
filler I mean I think it'd be better to
fill it with sawdust than this
ingredient okay it's also in condiments
it's in flavorings even my nutritional
products I had to pay extra to make sure
that it wasn't in our electrolyte
powders and I did a video on this and I
compared different products and you can
there's a test it's called a starch test
add a couple drops of iodine to it and
if there's a certain ingredient in there
okay it'll turn dark purple okay and if
there's not it'll stay kind of
translucent yellow but it can be
classified as zero sugars did you guess
what it is yet all right this is what it
is molto dextrin there's other names for
molto dextrin too like dextrin modifi if
IED food starch glucose syrup corn syrup
so maltodextrin is a highly highly
processed ingredient okay they maybe
start with GMO corn and then they refine
it and then they add an acid to it and
it started out as a starch and really a
starch is a bunch of glucose molecules
connected together and so maltodextrin
is a polysaccharide poly meaning many
saccharides mean meaning sugars so it's
many sugars connected together so it's
considered a starch when they go through
the process of adding acid that's called
hydrolysis basically that's a process
where they chop up this starch into tiny
pieces and it's not fully broken down
into glucose molecules but it's very um
refined and it's broken up partially so
they can still legally call it a starch
but this is a highly processed starch
it's not like a like a potato something
like that it's it's more of an
industrial ultr process food but I don't
want to call it food because it doesn't
resemble food and uh it doesn't have all
the vitamins and minerals like even
other starches might have to protect you
against all the oxidated damage that
it's going to create but when it goes in
your body it spikes your sugar more than
actual sugar does okay and it creates a
lot of gut inflammation gas and bloating
and it Alters the microbiome to the
point where you have less diverse good
bacteria microbiome uh there's also
reports that it creates leaky gut so
it's not good for your digestive system
and sometimes it creates an over
fermentation so basically you're going
to get more gas more bloating but other
than that it's going to be totally fine
well not to mention the glyphosate the
herbicide that comes along with it
because when you're processing like corn
or even like the wheat you're not just
going to have that carbohydrate you're
going to have other chemicals with it
not to mention gluten I didn't even talk
about that so the two loopholes that
multiexon uses is one uh you can
classify it as a zero carb even though
it could be 500 milligrams of material
which is crazy and even though it acts
like a sugar actually worse than a sugar
they don't have to call it a sugar they
call it a carbohydrate and people have
this idea that oh carbohydrates are
healthier than sugars right well not in
this case and if we take a look at all
of the ultra process food ingredients
like all the junk food ingredients my
viewpoint is that this thing is the
worst of all of those I mean if you can
think of something that's worse than
this please comment down below but if
you look at the research on this I mean
it's it's crazy and it's considered safe
second loophole okay grass this is a way
to bypass the FDA so they don't have to
go through all this process of getting
approved they can just basically claim
that it's safe and submit the form and
Presto it's safe because industry says
it's safe this is how they get a lot of
toxic chemicals into the environment as
well they call it generally recognized
is safe so anytime you see that that is
not by the FDA that is by industry
they're basically telling you it's safe
so the big problem is this maltodextrin
is in so many different foods in the
grocery store uh you're gonna have just
have to start reading the labels and uh
like I said before you know watch out
for the word multitran anything with
multiex corn starch food food starch
glucose syrup corn syrup so if you're
trying to lose weight or trying to be
healthy that is one ingredient that you
want to stay away from now because of
the censoring and the suppressing of the
algorithms on YouTube it's becoming more
difficult to find my content and there's
a lot of content that I cannot put on
YouTube unfortunately so to make sure
you have full access of all my
information go to drberg.com And
subscribe to my newsletter by clicking
the link Down Below in the description I
will see you on the other
side